[Musik]
ich habe dieses jahr viel reden gehört
von den gräben die es zwischen den
städten und dem land geben soll
existiert natürlich den graben zwischen
land und stadt bevölkerung statt
landkarten das thema der linksgrünen
städter die angeblich das land
bevormunden wollen die anzüge des bestes
der anfühlt sich bevorzugt streifen am
rand der stadt land graben spielt in der
tat bei bestimmten themen besonders
stark
offensichtlich gibt es in der schweiz
urbane und ländliche lebenswelten wo die
menschen unterschiedlich ticken
[Musik]
in solche lebenswelten willich
eintauchen und mit dem phänomen stadt
land graben annähern
[Musik]
die stadt zürich ein anziehungspunkt
auch für viele menschen die auf dem land
aufgewachsen sind sowie der geograf und
politikwissenschaftler michael herrmann
ein spezialist wenn es um stadt wird das
land fragen geht er stammt ursprünglich
aus huttwil im emmental
der stadt und bitte dass er jetzt steht
ich habe sozusagen das man mitbringt
verliert man natürlich nie was ist das
also
ca die normative oder das vom land sieht
das ist so bin ich aufgewacht
weil sie eben ein wiedersehen sagt die
studierte die haben wir nicht brauchen
und auf dem land da wird noch richtig
schafft und dass er jedes stück ist auch
wie komisch und des stockes technik sie
also die bilder an ihre tür auch immer
noch
vom land nochmals herab aus toll hier
habe in der stadt über die jahre
festgestellt dass es gleichgesinnte
oftmals an den gleichen ort ziehen
dazu
wird meist für sich ein solcher ausstieg
und trotzdem nimmt der gruppe ebene zu
auf der suche nach spannungsfeldern
zwischen stadt und land bin ich
immobilie ist der winter gelandet hier
geht es um die frage was mit alten
landwirtschafts gebäuden ausserhalb der
bauzonen geschehen soll
diese frage ist im raumplanungsgesetz
geregelt rechtsanwalt und cvp politiker
und vater sagt dass es bei der
raumplanung differenzen gebe zwischen
den wir sagt urban geprägten bundes
behörden und den bergkantonen das hat
auch der basler christoph birkenmeier
erlebt er wollte hier im wehntal mehrere
hunderttausend franken investieren in
den umbau einer alten stall scheune
lebens die unterstellungen und
eine 3 die man das immer ihr untersteht
direkt ihm verrat es geht direkt in euer
genau das mit der mobile also wie gesagt
nicht was existiert
eine expertenkommission des kantons
wallis hat diese stallscheune ausserhalb
der bauzonen als schützenswert erachtet
der umbau wurde bewilligt unter strengen
auflagen
vor ort ist auch der einheimische theo
imhof hier hätte den stall verkaufen
wollen
in der woche damit
zum zweck genutzt sowohl klein also von
außen unverändert von außen wird man
nicht sehen da sind keine neuen fenster
keine
davor den boden nicht begradigen ich
werde hier kein sitzplatz machen wir
keinen star leben machen ich will ja
keine
fahnenstange und kein grillplatz
dass sich aber wichtig dass will dass
ich nach re und das dass ich das will
ich nicht gleich was gibt eine örtliche
schreinerei natürlich hätte ich mit
einer gemacht bin kämpft darum dass der
dorfladen erhalten bleiben ich meine man
kann lade mir ja natürlich würde ich
hier einkaufen also ja klar
doch die beamten des bundesamtes für
raumentwicklung in bern legten rekurs
ein die stallscheune sei nicht
schützenswert
der ärger über gebärden der beamten ist
hier groß
nach die starken gäste von der zentrale
jährige dass die bisher nicht mehr wir
sind einzelne bürger wissen nicht wann
zuletzt gar kein sprung machen das
ändert nichts dass man filme trug konnte
geht immerhin hielt er sich immer noch
das rücklicht eigentlich ist auch vor
der konnte nicht das wird immer weniger
berücksichtigt er hätte aber das
misstrauen gegenüber den
meisten opfer und der geist ist da drin
und die juristisch vertraten die
absolute extrem einige aber in dem
tempel vorher quasi kein stahl eröffnete
ich als ferienhaus das heißt es gibt ok
um nutze ich obwohl das ist es nicht
wenn einer stadt wohnt hätte so weg der
woche bezog und weiß nicht was mein
enkel ist im kommen ist auch
das ist einfach so
dass das licht ob das auto
die wahrheit 60 fahrt beim bundesamt für
raumentwicklung sagte man mir es sei für
den charakter der landschaft gefährlich
wenn nicht mehr benötigte stelle zu
ferienhäusern umgewandelt werden man
müsse dosiert und umsichtig vorgehen
auch ing ist darum sorge zur landschaft
zu tragen
zwei trainings initiative zeigt das
schweizer volk eigentlich will das in
der bar weniger blut wird das müssen wir
akzeptieren
dass ich damals die hort dadurch extrem
sie werden zürich stehen werde nicht
ablehnen ja der betrachter kanton hat
das abgelehnt er den betroffenen zur
tz viel interpretationsspielraum aber
lte lässt sie nicht betroffene mehr
hannover die betroffenen minderheit
die gemeinde bin die vom
bevölkerungsschwund betroffen ist hat
den umbau unterstützt aber am schluss
gab das bundesgericht in einer
umstrittenen und knappen entscheidung
den raum planen in bern recht aus der
stallscheune darf keine wohnen werden
reagiert materie socrates rufen wenn
aber die stadt der moderne sich
weil anzeiger was was hier schutzwürdig
soll sie und was nicht dass das ist aus
meiner sicht eine klare konturen
competence ob es wirklich nur die städte
sind das muss hier offen bleiben
klar ist der stadt-land-graben beim
thema wolf
wir sind unterwegs in der val lumnezia
dem tal des lichtes im kanton graubünden
sofort links
während der diesjährigen badesaison hat
den wolf im kanton graubünden über 100
schafe und ziegen gerissen eine
herausforderung für bauen wie erwähnt
hallo ihr stoff
mittagessen
fertig wir ware jahre zu scharf mit
ein neues jagdgesetz hätte den kantonen
mehr kompetenzen gegeben unter anderem
für präventive abschüsse des wohls doch
das schweizer volk sagte letzten herbst
nein
das
würde durch stadt gesetzes treten
ja sehr
19.12 müsste mache doch unter strom
nicht mehr
rund 120 schafe hat ein paar dutzend
hier in mainz es ist
albern und
davon ob sie
das rudel immer unterwegs
ja was bisher abstimmen aber mir
ist das bitter nötig sieht die sache und
jetzt geht das problem dass ja oder es
wird schlimmer und schlimmer in alte
problem warf couchepin ist das im
internet alle abschießen zu springen
aber
auch schon so schön und gehört
er seit dort 23 wahlforscher zug
gesprungen sind und wenn die alter
säugling schnee weg
das problem ist dass rudolf der sieht
wenig später sprengte fahrt tradition
geht es dann treten die jungen das ist
ja so stadland problematik
und würde wohl
der hand
schließlich bricht drüber schoss und
oberes bild wird dann hier zeigt wie es
wirklich ist also gerissene schafe leben
oder paar welt von ihnen dass alle wände
herzig finden dass wir dieter wolf sind
aber knefs der us-kinostart ist
praktisch nichts zu tun aber
wesentlich höher ist das einfach die
problem wolfgang schüssel der inneren
schnell das ja der barumer es geht
seehofer wahl von bismarck der bisher
stellen die es ja nicht wenn dir nach
sind beim jagdgesetz haben sie hier in
der gemeinde lumnezia so verloren aber
oftmals sind die landregionen auf der
gewinnerseite
so sagte die gemeinde im vergangenen
juni klar nein zu den beiden agrar
initiativen und vor allem zum co2 gesetz
ein herzensprojekt viele städte
dagegen
wehren
wenn
das kulturhaus der gemeinde lumnezia
trotz der viel sprudel indikation
die ausstellung der wolf in der kultur
zeigt das tier aus faszination aber auch
als bedrohung diese ambivalenz sollte
hier spürbar werden anlässlich einer
diskussionsrunde zwischen einheimischen
und gästen durfte auch ich ein paar
fragen stellen
in wien heute ganz spitz tracht mit
entscheiden wie wir hier ein bündel im
bündnerland und wir wollen es mit dem
mond von gab
es ist klar was die bundeswehr aber
natürlich
kann töten störend sind warum er ein
paar jeder abschnitt aus
regionen in verschiedenen demokratischen
prozess sich den menschen
dabei umgang außer dass ich richtig und
dass ich bald im umgang mit dem wolf es
geht so unglaublich unterschiedliche
perspektive unterschiedlicher
wirklichkeiten eigene die rechte und ul
bei der hypo belagerung
der bombenfund umgewandelt worden
eine kontroverse aber kultiviert devils
diskussion
später sind wir gast bei
ausstellungsleiterin anna louise julie
sie sagt kunz können in diesem
spannungsfeld zwischen stadt und land
als brückenbauer dienen
verstanden ist die abstimmung vom
letzten herbst nicht nur um der wolfgang
und zu schwer das an das risiko
untersucht oder das lied schon merken
oben gerichtet irgendwie lockerer dass
man kann regulieren und das ist auch das
was sie von ihnen touristen im haus die
medienstelle können in lorca dass sie
sehr viel auszuschalten und die anders
sind
die idee war dass ich mir gar nicht
bewusst
und wenn man drüber reden gesagt ihr
spinnt doch die freiheit h zum zum
richter dass sie da auch könnte das
keine zieles nummern der wolf kann leben
so emotional dieses thema auch sein mag
das jagdgesetz ist eine ausnahme die
einwohner auf dem land haben in den
letzten drei jahren bei abstimmungen
viel öfter gewonnen als die großen
städte die städte haben zu mehreren
initiativen jahr gesagt zb für
bezahlbare wohnungen die land kantone
haben diese und andere initiativen
bachab geschickt
dennoch halte sich den aufschrei in den
städten in grenzen vielfach herrscht
wieder abstimmen das land
also für häufiges tür gesetzt dass die
große stadt aber auch zwischen
heimatlied natürlich stadt das
wahnsinnig dominantes
und ich hoffe dass die trends der häufig
unter stadt durch untersagt autos vom
band und das für das q4
dominiert jedoch - die visa bevor
schrieb wie mit sie heidi nur wo es aber
darum es abschnitt in der politik so
warum häufiger umgekehrt ich bei steht
überblickt werden damit auf dem land mit
werden jetzt so richtig ein
diese gefühlslage lässt sich politisch
gut abholen
im juni feiert der svp spezi tiefer
senkung des rahmenabkommens mit der eu
im kanton schwyz reden tun auch die
städte aus zürich die freiheit wohnt
wieder auf dem land nennt nationalrat
roger köppel seine rede
auch die heiligen
sind schon mit dem auto
und die könne zum teil ebenso klar was
diese verzehrt werde vom land die
anfühlt mich bestes die anfühlt sich
bevorzugt streifen am land und ich war
gerne mal tage oder warten sowohl strom
bot wie vor kritisch
[Applaus]
im wallis spricht der fraktionschef der
mit der partei matthias präger am ersten
august vom stadt land graben er macht
sich stark für den finanzausgleich
zwischen den kantonen und gegen den wolf
nachdem die drohen nun als das land
graben und damit meine damen und herren
die nächste zerreißprobe für unser land
eine zerreißprobe die wir als kleines
wenn auch reiches land eigentlich gar
nicht ertragen wie zerbrechlich ein
einzelner staat kleinbild weil sich das
band der solidarität langsam löst erlebt
das kommt gerade am leib der vielen
gerissenen schafe was der wolf im goms
und in anderen regionen sowie aktuell
anrichtet ist eine katastrophe
das jagdgesetz gesetzte damen hätte hier
abhilfe geschaffen
aber das schwingende vertrauen
verständnis zwischen stadt und land hat
dieses zum scheitern gebracht die
konsequenzen sind leider blutig die
bauern im goms leiden die bauern im
oberwallis leiden und hier
müssen wir helfen
am gleichen tag macht svp präsident
markus eine kampfansage gegen die
linksgrünen städte die luxus linken und
bipro münder grünen linde städten wollen
alle andere im inland vorschreiben wie
sie denken und leben sollten die luxus
linken und bevor münder grünen leben
ohne bezug zur realität der meisten
menschen in diesem land soll ein
massiver angriff steht und jetzt haben
wir das nach oben geht und das würde die
ziehen wir jetzt
sagte er bei dieser antrag eine brauche
das
ja das ist ja nicht vorstellbar
und das heißt hier das hat waren nämlich
jetzt
dominieren
und da war dominiert der kamera da ist
als bei gängigen gequält dabei gibt es
auch für die großstädter sensible themen
wo sie sich mehr verständnis erhoffen
von den menschen in den agglomerationen
und auf dem land insbesondere wenn es um
mobilität und verkehr geht
eine hiermit männer unterwegs
ist für den ist
für mich ist jede einfach alarm
belästigung einer
klappe und wetter innehat wenn die hand
mit dem wettbewerb das ist mir aber dass
die da hinten los denn richtig
die stadtzürcher grüne politikerin gabi
petri ist eine die zwischendurch gerne
hindernisse aufstellt
die geschäftsführerin des vcs zürich
will weniger autos und somit weniger
parkplätze in der stadt zum ärger von
außerstädtischen gewerbetreibenden und
manchen pendlern die freie fahrt in die
stadt wünschen mit ihr bin ich angelangt
in der lebenswelt großstadt
hamburg ballett morgen fiel zurück vor
wenn sich das
sensationell damals der verehrung zu tun
könne für sorge dass die straße wieder
bestätigt straße das heißt dass ein
städtisches straße
wird statt
ich glaub vertraglich stump wenig wäre
einfach zum queren will aber nur feinde
sieht dafür die straße queren da costa
und das ist schon wichtig dass den
straßen und darf ich nichts höre krieg
hat aber irgendwie klar die waren die
wahl weil an den start vor nur die dafür
die vielfach haben
benötige ich mit dem auto scott aus
mitte bauen können als jetzt aufhören
dann hat sie so wie sie
kontaktieren aber eins nach dem 3 die
auch vom ausgang heike und das braucht
nur eine richtung zürich letzten haben
mit dem man den kollegen anderen ich
fertig bin 8 uhr
auf deiner sagt john teenager umgebracht
und studenten verteilt außenplatz ihnen
die tat des euro sollen verleitet sie in
deinem zimmer
nein eigentlich aber zur abschiebung
[Musik]
das lied ist stadt können besucher und
gemüse sich rücksichtslos verhalten
könnte das miteinander esskultur und ich
sage nicht in der hand vor das sind 10
euro zurückgehalten richtig der hat ab
und zu als andere kantone setzen
erschienen da im zug wo 16 franken so
verbrauchen nicht dass mir da darf ein
fahrer und mannschaften das guten namen
baut so forderte hotspots
sind ja nicht einfach nur den osten
tourenfahrer sich immer mehr ab
wir sind höchst sitze ohne den stoff
hält eigentlich alles ja sonst hier was
hält der stadtzürcher bliebe ohne dass
darin wird auf zürich kommt etwas
missglückt unsere tour das euro blieb da
haben wir
werden
den kampf auf dem markt in oerlikon
macht petri werbung für den neuen
verkehrsrichtplan der stadt
sie könnten mit der stadt zürich
weniger öffentliche parkplätze mehr fuss
und veloverkehr ist teil davon
das kommt nicht bei allen gut an
die stadt zürich der
richtplan da bitte ich die reservisten
der masse hätte kein parkplatz wären
jetzt
aber
eva tasche
durchsuchen ich auf einmal macht und
erfüllt damit will uns vor so im
sogenannten transit wenn sie vom
heiraten vom schaufenster porsche das
ist immer noch
das auto vor dem ausnahme er hat das
ganze problem gelöst das ist ganz
große landschaft
arbeitsplatz
gabi petri setzt sich nicht nur für
velos ein
auf ihrer homepage macht sie sich auch
stark für den wolf und gegen die jagd
das ist es uns allen das blut ohne titel
das verhältnis zwischen sehnsucht nach
land hand oder und die dealer ein
leichter zu kommen zur natur möglich und
lud wo man glaubt der lehrerin
nutzerorientierte zuordnungen und sein
das stört die waage und seite haben
besucher und tv täglich weit weg von der
parteilinie möglich linie zwischen stadt
und land uhr
vom berg tal bis nach zürich bin ich
gefahren auf der suche nach dem stadt
land graben
dabei habe ich aber die mitte vergessen
sagt der politikwissenschaftler das ist
typisch dass das meistens für so aber
dagegen dass wahl ist so richtig
und rasch
die beine stellen aber weder hier noch
direkt und der stadt lagen glaube ich
hätte also pole gar nicht auseinander ob
die zwischenschnitte grad gefühlt
sondern die meisten sie trotz haben dazu
ist schon vier jahre wieder
das davoser auseinanderdriftet immer
noch behauptet das braucht man die
eigenen
[Musik]
die mitte das sind vor allem die
agglomerationen und die kleinstädte des
mittellandes
hier werden abstimmungen meist
entschieden
[Musik]
heute bin ich in frauenfeld
ich möchte an einem auftritt des
schriftstellers pedro lenz
sein programm spielt vom lebensgefühl
mittel und
pedro lenz der mann aus langenthal hat
jährlich bis zu 200 lesungen die meisten
davon in kleinstädten und dörfern
da spüre er mehr brücken als gräben
interessante stars
jeder vorstand kennt großstadt
ist großstadt muss kino derart krass
kaluga
rolling stones colossus basic jeden
dienstag ein großstadt was auch gut
bewegen keine vertrauenskrise
analysieren oder ins konzert das macht
es dir vor du nord
verschiedenheit gebäude und
weniger die top-5 der blase oder gewinnt
aber es gibt eine reale welt nach bronze
vor wenn interfax außerdem bayern oder
dem base de roni sagte heute anderem
titanic
szene club
sogar bis ins quartier und
sagen das
geht nicht
ich habe mir
das gar nicht machen können
und das geld gar nicht
minister mitteilen umgang fing das ist
die zeit die die vermischung von der
sozialen schichten vor dieser magische
geschichte es geht es so wie das
eingestellte ganze städte gegenüber
moment
dass man nichts weiter sagen mit den
bayern vorbei sie haben die möglichkeit
das ist das nicht wirklich was geklickt
wird nicht
nach bern beginnen aber
möglich dass sie da
[Gelächter]
man spricht
neben dem verfahren immer wieder bietet
das eeg
nötigen mittel am schweizer landtag
roland parkplatz land schweizer
gartenhof center land sydlik spray
landet mit fast atlantik war es an der
kletterwand
aromatischer saarland kasperletheater
land radio island of scotland notiert
heute standort zum gratis land
autobahnzubringer land beim brüttiseller
kreuz 5 km stau wegen
verkehrsüberlastung wird auf 18 meter
und
landschaften aber wieder fahren
auch wenn pedro lenz vom mittelland und
von der kleinstädtischen schweiz
schwärmt die formel gutes land böse
stadt stimme für ihn definitiv nicht
aber das eben das blatt einen degen oder
dass das mit der weder nur weil es sie
die gute weil sie die schlechte und das
ist so eine authentische verkleide ich
die idee dass die verbrauchen ist die
achte beste wünsche sie und der stadt
sagt sabine rumpf
und tastatur mit bastian aber das ist
heute
entlassen konflikte die
sache dass zum beispiel rechner war mit
dem zögern mit der perfekte verbinde and
road hoffentlich vielen danke bessere
mannschaft flog verschlechtern
sollte darüber läge ja warum fatal ist
mehr und tatsächlich
stand
im leben aber einige software sondern
sich auch das umsteigen und
sorgfältig alle wochensieger frau
geführt tradition es gibt tatsächlich
spannungsfelder in der schweiz
mehr austausch und gespräche würden
helfen dann wird die schweiz am stadt
land graben erwachsen als dass sie daran
zerbricht
[Musik]